Harmony the circus hair hanging is a
stunning circus art that isn't actually
widely practiced so catching it in
person is a very rare treat but guess
where you can catch it right here in Las
Vegas of course at the cosmopolitan's
revamped version of opium you're
watching Elena Suarez she is the newest
act to join the Spiegel world show and
now she is here straight from the
Starship opium to tell us more welcome
hello hello you're wearing your opium
outfit yes I'm liking it it's very
Cosmic very spaceship Chic
now okay I was watching that and I am
just so inspired and impressed with the
hair hanging act are you okay does your
head hurt I'm okay what does it cause
you it doesn't hurt at all of course
it's hard I'm not gonna lie but you know
we make it in a safe way yeah so of
course you know it's a very precise
technique what is the technique well
it's a it's a tradition it's a secret
and we keep it like this for safety and
to keep the tradition oh wow you can't
tell us
oh my I heard there's a braid and
there's a hoop that's all I know yes I
respect the tradition and of course
safety is first so okay you gotta just
go and see her do it yeah to understand
right okay now what inspired you to
learn to learn this art because like I
said it's not widely practiced no not
everybody is brave enough yeah it's very
unique skill uh I'm a dancer and I found
another way to dance with her hanging a
lot of freedom to move so I enter in the
circus World a few years ago and I just
fell in love wow so I wanted to use my
dance skills and bring them to the air
well we're watching you again right now
and it's just incredible it's such a
sight to see and this is the newest act
in opium the revamp the rebranded show
so what else is making it revamped
outside of you yeah recently we reopened
the show with new acts and of course
it's still a fun sexy ranchy show so
yeah you guys family friendly right you
can expect the unexpected but we have
new uh new acts acrobatics we have
contortion we have percussion we have
limbo I don't want to say too much but
we have an amazing cast it's just you
gotta go that's all I can say because
when I tell you I was clutching my
pearls throughout that show like oh
my god wow yes it's Gonna Keep you like
this is the full show it's hilarious and
it's raunchy but it's so good now you're
new to the Spiegel World family you know
what's been your experience so far how
is it it's amazing it it feels like a
family really and it's so fun like it's
not only what we do on a stage is also
what it happens at the stage and all the
crew that make it possible and I'm so
grateful and happy to be here honestly I
love it if you have seen opium you got
to go back because it is brand new and
including hair hanging so you do not
want to miss that um opium has two shows
a night at the Cosmopolitan at seven and
nine PM Wednesday through Sunday for
tickets head to school